- right where's that light coming from
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play fibrillation
okay
now this is a game that I found a while
ago that it's not exactly a new game I
think it's a little old but some vodka
he'll follow I'm not exactly sure what
the hell's going on but from what I've
read wow that was impressive
it's more of an atmospheric um adventure
type game more than what's going on here
hey what's going on here close eye huh
why would I need to close my eyes
haha yeah it's not an explicitly horror
based game you know as opposed to some
that are more on like absolute air and
stuff like this it's mostly it's
designed to be and it was going on an
immersive type of game which I am now
very interested in because this looks
really cool and that voice acting sounds
very familiar Ike what oh god watch
blink what the hell is that I don't know
there weren't any evidence of monsters
in any of the screenshots so I don't
even know if there's a threat the blood
on the notes not blowing the ground so I
don't really know what I'm doing here or
why or how as far as I know I was out in
like some Antarctic scene there so I
wore was totally tripping man but oh
wait
I wake up at some point I'm totally
tripping man yeah brick just tripping
that was totally not just a giant worm
thingy that probably could destroy your
hand how high can I jump here
aha what the hell was that what was that
I might have supposed to be up here
sorry sorry I'll go now I'll go now yeah
so I found this a link for this game is
in the description below if you find it
interesting enough to play it for
yourself I'm already thinking that I
might want to recommend it I mean the
voice acting is all right but you know
compared to some games there's a lot
worse that they could do okay I guess
I'm just continuing to move this way
I really have a clear objective other
than stay away from the giant worm
that's all I've gathered so far Oh what
the hell what was that looks like a lamb
more than anything hmm huh oops right
then it's over here I can't see anything
is there anything over here no doesn't
look like it I really like the way the
light works in this game I don't know
what engine this is made off of anyway
these are stacked up here I can only
assume that I'm supposed to jump up on
them or maybe if I can jump which I
can't because I'm an idiot hurr Durr
okay maybe not maybe maybe maybe not
maybe not oh look at that
what uh what was that okay why does I
keep happening that's all yeah light
that I don't see around here I'm not
sure man
I'm blinking I'm blinking okay let me go
back a bit I don't know what I'm
supposed to do I saw I thought yeah
there's a stairwell here oh maybe I can
push a box
no can't push a box that would be too
easy how do I get in there I went around
but I didn't quite see away on aha here
we go okay I'm an idiot it's right here
I got it
oh that with my desk just shook for some
reason really don't like this no kidding
ah that sounds like the voice for the
bear in forget-me-not Annie that guys
now is it it really sounds like him
like no joke I thought maybe I'm wrong
what
yeah what is it what is it what is it
what's going on what's going on why why
tell me why
give me a reason give me a reason to be
afraid okay okay
carrying on nothing bad gonna happen
what happened what what I don't see
anything
you gotta stop panicking when I'm not
panicking man cuz we need to be calm
here excuse me
hurt me okay dead end don't go that way
oh where is dead end I'll go this way
not dead end crying ladies are never
good in horror games go away go away
Mary you don't know this lady no you
don't know this lady shut up Mary
okay all right so now that we're getting
away from the crying lady let's never go
near her again and then let's get out of
this weird building that got constructed
before our eyes and I don't know oh no I
don't know it all oh boy
I am descending into hell I'm stuck on
SCP oh eight seven now oh joy anything
under the stairs nope bah what the hell
hey I was walking there I might have
wanted to go back to see Mary
it sounded like high heels clacking at
what da hell whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
okay something is definitely going on
here don't know what it is but it's
something thing kind of reminds me of
city 17 in a few ways I don't know why
but it do
at least I can clearly see my running
meter I like that in a game when they
actually show you how much sprint you
have left helps you use it tactically
tactically oh boy oh lordy
oh boy okay here we go what the hell is
that
Oh what was that
why holy crap huh run run you ass bag ah
used up all my running shoes oh no oh no
oh no oh oh
right-ho jump Oh jump jump jump jump
dumb go down holy balls that thing's
still following me
I don't see anymore okay I don't know
the hot stout hair huh can we get away
huh where am I Wow falling weii fine
this is a seminal what's going on here
whoa
this game is freaky
I burned hey Birds how's it going hi oh
yeah what this dream is taking forever
but AM nightmare enough already
enough okay maybe it's not the bear that
didn't Oh I [ __ ] up oh no I didn't
[ __ ] up oh god damn okay follow the
lines I guess follow the lines and the
sound oh god this is like the labyrinth
not unlike this I don't like this at all
I'm really impressed with the level of
design I mean this is this is an indie
game and it seems like a lot of work
went into this I'm very very impressed I
don't even know what engineer was made
on might even be custom for all I know
oh I don't even know what that thing hi
bird by bird I'm gonna fall on the lines
just spawn the lines I'm gonna skip
ahead of line and go to this one
following the lines avoiding the giant
smoke worm and I like I have a loss as
to what the hell is going I'm just going
in a circle that's not fair all right
whatever let's just keep following the
sparks that's obviously the way I'm
supposed to go so let's go that way
I heard something here's all like I hear
something I hear something
oh I see you you're way over there
though hey you never got to give me all
the way over here I'm too smart for you
what is this over here umm planks of
wood not useful at all okay keep
following the line avoid giant worm what
the hell is that
what is that huh just a part of the
dreamworld I guess I would like a bit
more of a story narrative I might be
nice so far I haven't really gathered
anything that intro sequence didn't
explain a lot it was like sirens maybe
so maybe there was an accident of some
sort or someone got hurt or his wife got
hurt or he is in a coma and his wife is
crying by his side and this is him
trying to escape but these are all just
guesses and I don't know I'm hoping more
will be revealed later on and I hope it
I'm hoping that this line will lead me
to where it needs to get me very soon
and haha no okay
gonna get there eventually
maybe I'm just gonna be stuck wandering
these halls try to avoid the giant worm
well hello
trying to avoid giant worm trying to
avoid giant worm haha Wow
I don't look at it oh where the hell did
that thing come from
geez I'm lucky it turned left and not
right oh it's making a secret it's
making a cycle I gotta go I gotta go now
like now ah oh [ __ ] I'll close my eyes
okay close my eyes okay go go go go go
go go yeah go away crows [ __ ] off close
my eyes don't need to see you I'm
closing my eyes I don't know what
closing my eyes does okay I'm almost out
almost out almost uh don't go crazy just
yet breath do not go crazy just yet
bread what is this what is this why am i
up here oh I see rooftops over there huh
okay okay
trying to find a way out of here my
vision is still little wonky
I don't think closing my eyes actually
helps I think I'm just in permanent
wonky mode but I'm gonna gum it a break
free
wait a minute those look like hospital
equipment those look like hospital
monitors and that looks like a hospital
light so I'm guessing I was right this
guy is in the hospital I'm pretty sure
he's the one
see there anything else clues in the sky
no yeah I'm pretty sure this guy is the
one in the hospital and that might have
been his I might have been right in as
his wife crying on his side I escaped
I'm running free yeah hello anybody am I
free did I win did our one oh whoa hello
ah what is this
another feature pool huggy
oh boy back into the pit
I like stairs yeah stairs stop pondering
stairs
you think stairs are weird didn't you
see the giant worm crawling around your
brain maybe that's maybe that's what it
is he ate some bad sushi and he got a
parasite and it's infecting his brain
that's it yeah that's it ah okay now
hello what the hell is that phone
stopped going weird on me I'm trying to
concentrate here hello don't fall down
and go man
lots of stairs okay okay this is broken
all right moving forward even though I
have no idea why or how or when er whoa
okay okay okay okay what's going on
what's going on man we're you doing to
me we do to me we do thee
hmm I just get a bad feeling that
something's crawling around right around
the walls around me it's gonna come
busting through the walls at any minute
anybody know is this just a perpetual
staircase it is isn't it
I see it looping you're you're [ __ ]
with me I'm not going anywhere I've been
here before
oh wait what yeah I have this before you
ported me out of here don't do it again
you a ho I've been here before and now I
will escape a through here more stairs
me love stairs okay
I guess when something goes following me
look I've never had a greater sense of
paranoia in a game what the hell is that
what was that didn't even see what that
was I can barely see what I'm doing now
worm whoa whoa ha oh oh oh okay calm
down
there's the X rays with this place looks
real enough yeah except for what's going
on what's happenin
Wow Birds yeah what are you doing here
we're alone okay more x-rays leading me
to believe that there this guy isn't an
accident that's that is what is it I
don't even know what that is
anyway so my vision is now thoroughly
Wonka fide and I am going to continue on
my route to find the origin of my
insanity I'd make a good name for a band
origin of insanity ah you can write that
down but give me 25 cents every time you
play a note every note okay where am I
going
hey my so I'm supposed to climb up and
out and over the fence okay maybe maybe
oh no I don't think no I don't think I
can even jump that high well where'd
this come from
this is always been here yeah whatever
let's go to get higher my brother do you
I just
what is that blink nothing okay ah oh no
what am I supposed to do go back but do
what am I gonna do
why have you forsaken me okay there's a
line going from there there Oh God in
the whole Bluff [ __ ] [ __ ] watch your
mouth buddy
I'm an idiot there's staring me right in
front of the face I should always just
follow the lines okay which way do I go
guys decide which way I go eenie or
meenie
what about my knee maybe Moe mean II
know this would mean II
okay Meany stick my eye through the hole
just like an SCP oh eight seven B and
then the giant [ __ ] right into my eye
huh my eye okay
carrying on oh it's going in a circle
isn't it it's going in a circle isn't it
it is it is it isn't and wait no I
thought for sure that was it no
apparently not
where am I haha where the heck am i why
were those stairs so arduously slow
where am i I'm lost I think that's the
point of the game but I'm lost I'm lost
where's me I'm moving eat my mommy
okay going down now something's gonna
happen I mean I was writing that this
isn't a very jump scary game but the
atmosphere is like spot-on it's amazing
oh wow Oh God
oh yeah right oh my gosh Oh God going oh
yeah I go holy balls
Oh God Oh who the [ __ ] is girl I can't
read Express credit
oh the mozz oh god why did I go down
there why did I go down there why did I
go down I'm never going down there again
this is so following me I'm gonna assume
it is [ __ ] that in every way
holy crap I'm not going back there
oh uh uh no I laughs [ __ ] huh oh it's
way do I go
I don't know this way ah no not that way
Oh Ron Ron you bastard you died giving
guru's friend
Oh God Oh what do I do
SCORM oh so freaky
ah so wrong oh it's so wrong
Oh God what are you oh why are you
standing here what are you doing
what are you doing what are you doing
old man tell if I go to my happy play
oh hey balls ba ba ba going oh I can't
look at you I'm not gonna look at you
I'm not gonna oh wow
is this the point is this the point fell
on retreat a bit
whoa what hey hey now where I tell
Oh Oh God
Oh the worst I was the worst I was the
worst I was by far the worst Oh what
ah ha ha oh man yeah you're in a
hospital Brett oh man I was like oh God
oh man my throat hurts
I'm Dena means creaking that loud ooh
boy
I don't know what's up with the moss but
man okay where am i heart your heart
that was my heart okay yeah you're dead
now oh hello hi scientists excuse me
while I go insane not Birds ah dire
Birds
I gotta get up on this Hill for some
reason hello okay yeah some [ __ ]
[ __ ] with a camera doesn't jump out
of a corner right now screaming you're
on candid camera then there's only one
other possibility I'm dead yeah that
sounds about right
you really think candid camera has the
budget for this I mean I like it but
come on man
oh hello hi docks how you doing doing
okay alright
um I have anything important
no wait what oh that's a barrel I
thought it was another skull worm do not
like those things I lost my running
meter some reason we don't rack it my
guts are in knots
okay they're also on the floor because
you know you're dead being utilized by
doctors
oh hello I need to go there oh there's
the worm there's the big schmuck worm
that's what I'm looking for I'm coming
for you were me I don't know how long
this game is I don't think it has any
sort of save mechanic so I'm pretty sure
I have to play this in one go hmm
actually you know what I'm gonna cut
this here and I'm gonna cut it here with
fraps because my fraps have been bugging
I don't want to lose anything that I've
got so I'm gonna cut it here and then I
might stitch it together later if the
ending is pretty close but for now thank
you all so much for watching I mean I'm
really liking this click the link in the
description below I don't know if it's
free I don't remember I paid money for
this but click the link in the
description below this is an awesome
gift Gaia Birds cards yeah I'm trying to
do an outro [ __ ] out birds birds [ __ ]
off Birds get out here stop making my
vision all wobbly ok so thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos that I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye